some guy wrote some book and he said
that in fact uptown girl
wasn't about christy it's really about l
mcpherson this is the guy came out with
it i don't know that you told him this
they didn't get the whole story they got
part of it uh right i think what they
were trying to do was debunk that it was
all about christy
i wasn't even dating christy when i
started writing the song i was dating l
right and what a lineup of women it was
amazing it was just an amazing time
that's why i started writing a song
called uptown girls it was plural i
couldn't believe
you know the situation i was in i just i
couldn't believe this so you couldn't
believe the fact that you had met in one
in one just chance encounter you were
there with christy brinkley all
mcpherson and whitney houston the three
of them were swooning over you playing
the piano something i don't know if they
were swimming they were there all right
you know they were standing over the
piano i was playing i looked up and
there was christy brinkley all mcpherson
whitney houston anyway i was i wasn't
even dating christine when i started
writing this song
and it was i didn't remember what the
lyrics were but it was like uptown girls
and i've been all around the world is as
bad a lyric as the final lyric was it
was just corny is that is it always the
music was there already but you were
just trying to come up i had the music
it was almost like like a classical
piece
like a minuet
yeah
and then the left what they call that
the uh
uh bertom or something left hand
this is a classical term when you write
a song is that what you heard in your
head
no no not what i heard i'm just playing
a piano arrangement of it i heard like a
four seasons thing
she's a ranked uh you know one of those
kind of songs so so go ahead i'm so i
was dating you and then yeah when you
blow that off and you say you're dating
elle yeah she is one of the hot i mean
her body is perfection true yes she was
called the body she was called the body
yes and for how long did that go on
months no well yeah
a couple of months we dated on and off
it's not like we were you know engaged
or anything we just kind of dated i
can't even imagine
leaving elle mcpherson i didn't leave
her she left you well she went to europe
she was just starting out in a modeling
career she had been in the states for a
few months we dated and then she went to
europe i figured that was it right
that's that's romantic that yeah
and then i i started to date christy
nobody dumped anybody we just kind of
went different ways doesn't l mcpherson
get mad at christy for taking her
boyfriend no i wasn't really her
boyfriend it was never going to be that
oh okay we kind of knew that but did you
had you collected both their numbers on
that first night okay well not the first
i i think uh i contacted christy later
on down the road after elle and i had
stopped dating okay and then i started
dating christy and rather than to be
about all these different girls if she
became the uptown girl i started writing
about one person so it is about chris
yes oh because they got the story wrong
i actually felt bad for christy when
this came out because i said you know a
lot of christie's identity is being the
uptown girl and being the one who's in
that video and being billy joel's wife
and so for this book to come out and say
oh it's really about al mcpherson i bet
she was brokenhearted to hear that like
i i i think it probably bothered her i i
don't know but i'm supposed to call her
and say by the way that's not true i
want you to know honey this is about you
because i know you still care about her
you still you have feelings we're still
friends you're still friends so i i
think she knows what the story is though
i mean because we talked about it a long
time ago when this first story came out
but i had started writing it when i was
dating l that was the story and that was
it that's all there was to it wasn't
about help particularly because it was
originally called uptown girls give me a
little bit of it just just for the hell
of it i mean the actual song a little
bit a little bit don't do the whole
thing uptown girl not gonna be able to
do it let me drop the key
up down girl
she been living in her uptown world i
bet she never had a backstreet guy
i bet her mama never told her why
it's supposed to sound like frankie
valley but it doesn't it's too early in
the morning that was your that was your
tribute to frankie
but i heard it like you know what was
that song he was the rich guy and she
was the poor girl ragdoll right
he's she's from the wrong side of the
tracks and he can't go out with her
and you know what the lyric in that song
is
i love you just the way you want